hey guys it is September the 27th and my
name is Jess and you're watching games
but news that's up GTA 5's next content
update of deriving on october for the
new bike a themed dlc will bring
underground motorcycle clubs to the
forefront of the los santos and blaine
county criminal underworld new
cooperative and competitive gameplay
modes are also on the way alongside a
whole bunch of new vehicles weapons and
clothing one of the new bikes rockstar
shown off is the Western rat bike which
you can check out in a selection of new
screenshots you'll be able to form a
club with up to eight other people and
assign roles within it so good luck
working out who gets to be President
next up an n64 emulator has been removed
from the Xbox one within the same week
that it arrived news of the nintendo 64
app emerged on reddit earlier this week
in apparently lets you play classic n64
games like Super Mario 64 and mario kart
64 as you'd expect to the app called
win64 810 has since been removed
although people who have installed it
can reportedly continue to use it
eurogamer's reported that the app cost
the equivalent of 769 euro and was
hidden on the marketplace as it had not
received a Microsoft approve to release
although if you knew the name you could
search for it and find it a recent Xbox
one update enabled Windows Store apps to
run on Xbox one although as this case
shows Microsoft probably aren't going to
be keen on emulators and the like
running on their console finally
single-player campaign details have
emerged from battlefield one alongside a
new trailer that has had my producer
making noises all money the trailer
shows of the whole lot of the characters
and settings you'll be encountering
within the campaign of the world war one
shooter and it's pretty damn epic ahead
of its release the ESRB published their
rating for the game along with some
details about what's in store the
description explains that the game is
set in various locations during the
Great War and players will take on the
roles of a number of different
characters as the plot unfolds including
a fighter pilot and armor crewman a
rebel fighter and a mess
runner unsurprisingly the game has been
rated M for Mature because of all the
shooting and exploding and killing etc
etc for the full battlefield one trailer
head to our story on gamespot big game
is due out on october twenty one ps4
xbox one and pc let me know your
thoughts on today's stories head to
gamespot for stories on destiny and NBA
2k 17 and i will see you again tomorrow